[Music]
it is perhaps one of the most reviled
moments in cinema history a scene so
dumb so over the top that it
single-handedly killed a Beloved movie
franchise and yet here we are 15 years
later and I'm here to say that we were
all wrong about the fridge scene
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that just really hates snakes
like why did it have to be snakes so are
y'all hyped for Indiana Jones 5 no well
I'm not surprised the franchise has
definitely struggled to find its footing
in the modern era you see Indiana Jones
was huge when it was first introduced
back in the 1980s the brainchild of
producer George Lucas director Steven
Spielberg and movie star Harrison Ford
it was like the Holy Trinity of movies
at the time he had the guy behind Star
Wars the biggest director of the 20th
century and one of Hollywood's hottest
most recognizable Stars people loved
these movies and honestly how could you
not they were perfect action Adventures
starring an archaeologist who traveled
the world exploring tombs punching Nazis
and teaching inappropriately flirty
college students you're
a teacher part-time the Indiana Jones
Trilogy was Rock Solid and I don't know
a single person who wasn't satisfied
when India and his friends literally
rode off into the sunset at the end of
The Last Crusade thereby cementing this
character's Legacy and Cinema history
forever and then came the Shameless cash
grab greed gonna do what greed gonna do
and so in 2008 Lucas Spielberg and Ford
re-teamed up for Indiana Jones and the
kingdom of the Crystal Skull bring in
India out of retirement to play the hits
but with a Twist fighting Communists
reuniting with his first love and
introducing him to his son played by
Shia LaBeouf which was a choice he chose
poorly now to say that fan reception to
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull was mixed
would be one a heck of an understatement
let's start by renaming this film we'll
call it Indiana Jones and the policy of
no refunds how about Indiana Jones and
the mystery of why this movie didn't
work watching it again today with fresh
eyes I don't think it's the death of
Cinema like a lot of people said at the
time but it's certainly mid was
completely unnecessary most egregiously
of all just lost the spirit of The
Originals for a ton of people Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull was where the
franchise jumped the shark for the fun
adventure storytelling became too silly
too irreverent too unrealistic and if I
were to bet what happened here the fact
that Lucas and Spielberg were suddenly
able to use CGI no longer Tethered to
what could be done practically yeah I
think that was what was to blame here
it's almost like it's a pattern with
some of these guys all of a sudden this
very grounded series became more like a
video game than the old serials that
they were inspired by this is a movie
where Shia LaBeouf Swings with monkeys a
guy gets eaten alive by ants aliens melt
the villain's brain using mind bullets
oh you heard me mind bullets but of them
all one scene stood out as the moment
that the franchise died the moment that
it went past the point of no return I'm
talking of course about the fridge scene
since this movie was released 15 years
ago which means that maybe you've been
spared from this let me explain the
climax of the film's opening set piece
India is on the run from several Soviet
spies at a U.S military base in the
1950s he Ducks into a neighborhood to
hide from the rooskis but soon realizes
that something's not quite right this
Village is filled with mannequins not
people if you've ever played Call of
Duty Black Ops you'll immediately
recognize this as a doom town a fake
neighborhood constructed near nuclear
blast sites to see how atomic bombs
affect the average American basically it
was built to get blown up Suddenly Indy
hears an alarm blaring in the distance
realizing his predicament Indy hides
himself in a conveniently lead-lined
refrigerator to save himself from
nuclear Annihilation as the bomb goes
off he's blasted away from Ground Zero
safely crashing just far enough beyond
the blast radius to pose for a real cool
shot before he moves on with the rest of
the movie yeah I don't know about you
but I can absolutely see why this one
shattered the audience's suspension of
disbelief surviving a nuclear explosion
with your only protection being a
refrigerator yeah it was so ridiculous
that it coined a new term that was even
worse than Jumping the Shark nuking the
fridge in retrospect I think a lot of
the filmmakers realized that this was
just too much with Spielberg himself
personally taking the blame for this
quote silly scene back in 2011. George
Lucas however insisted a year later in a
New York Times interview that he was the
one who actually came up with the idea
as the story went Lucas drafted up a
six-inch thick dossier of research
demonstrating that quote the odds of
surviving that refrigerator from a lot
of scientists are about 50 50. okay well
sometimes science has more art than
science Morty a lot of people don't get
that of course that dossier has never
been made public leave me I looked and
so you know me loyal theorists I can't
just take a filmmaker's word on
something when you make a bold claim
like oh Indy would have survived that
stupid unrealistic atomic bomb scene I
need to run the numbers so let's just
end this debate once and for all could
Indiana Jones have survived nuking the
fridge I'm gonna be 100 honest with you
the answer will absolutely shock you but
even more surprising than the answer is
how we're gonna get there so grab your
whips and tip those fedoras it's time to
swing into it first we need to set some
parameters around our fridge and our
bomb the type of fridge that's used in
the movie is a king cool Standalone
refrigerator but since this was a
fictional brand created entirely for the
movie obviously there wasn't any hard
information about its dimensions and
makeup so instead we pulled out our
classic theorist pixel rulers and got to
measuring Harrison Ford is six foot one
inch tall using that information I was
able to determine that the fridge was
roughly 4.69 feet or 143 centimeters
tall and 2.61 feet or about 80
centimeters wide we're gonna be assuming
that it's roughly as deep as it is wide
to get a nice even rectangular prism
older fridges like this were made of
steel and were insulated with either
asbestos or fiberglass the standard for
insulation in a refrigerator like this
was about one inch so we're gonna be
using that for our numbers today that
being said we should also mention that
the movie goes out of its way to focus
on a shot saying that the fridge is
quote lead lined for Superior insulation
this is uh actually kind of ridiculous
for a home refrigerator which we're
gonna see in the numbers here in a
minute but for now we're just gonna run
with it okay so now that we know the
fridge we're talking about let's talk
about the other main factor here the
bomb specifically how powerful it is
though it's easy to think that a nuke is
a nuke is a nuke and that being so close
to one would instantly vaporize anyone
that isn't necessarily the case this is
where I Gotta Give old Georgie Boy a
point though you'd be hard-pressed to
survive a nuclear explosion at Ground
Zero if you're a little bit away from it
even as close as we see the explosion in
this movie it's not impossible for as
much as we think of dropping an atomic
bomb is resulting in the complete
decimation of a city hundreds of
thousands of people survived about
bombings in Hiroshima and Nagasaki so it
can be done there's just a lot of
variables affecting this sort of thing
so just how powerful is the bomb that we
see in Indiana Jones we can actually
approximate that thanks to military
records Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
takes place in Nevada in 1957 which
happens to be the exact time and place
where the US government was undergoing
operation plumb bob a series of 29
explosive nuclear tests with bombs
placed on the ground in balloons
underground and as we see in the movie
in Towers now you might be wondering why
they'd want to test bombs in the air
with balloons and Towers but detonating
them in the air is a way that militaries
will maximize the destructive energy of
an explosion but in the air the bomb's
energy is distributed over a wider area
meaning that you're likely dealing more
total damage on the ground this is a
concept known as an air burst and again
it was the way that the bombs were
detonated over Hiroshima and Nagasaki
anyway since we know that the bomb in
Indiana Jones was on a tower this then
Narrows down our listic candidates
comparing the size and shape of the
mushroom cloud in the film to footage
captured from operation plumb bob the
explosion most closely resemble pulls
that from a nuke code named Smokey which
had itself a yield of 44 kilotons that's
equal to 44
000 tons of TNT and it was detonated
atop a 700 foot Tower Additionally the
Smoky test occurred right here just a
few miles away from area 51. given the
comically large 51 on the hangar doors
that Indies escaping from this intro is
obviously supposed to take place there
so it's feasible that Indy would have
been able to make his way to the Smoky
detonation site through the desert on
foot while escaping the Soviets also I
couldn't find any evidence of operation
plumb bob using any Doom towns during
the experiments it seems like something
that they just added into the movie so
we're gonna be taking data from Doom
towns used in earlier 1955 tests as a
stand-in structures for these tests were
built approximately one mile or 1.61
kilometers away from Ground Zero which
again lines up nicely with what we can
eyeball from this scene in the film so
now that we know all of that it's time
to figure out if Indy could have
survived when it comes to death by
atomic bomb there are three main things
that we need to worry about the heat of
the explosion the blast wave that the
explosion makes and the radiation that's
left behind so let's just start off with
the heat when a bomb like this explodes
it releases a ton of thermal radiation
like a lot a lot the Fireballs from
these nuclear explosions can reach
temperatures equivalent to the interior
of the sun about a hundred million
degrees Celsius but the farther away you
get from the center the less intense
that that heat becomes and it falls off
fast according to the online tool nuke
map anyone within 2 miles or 3.21
kilometers of the explosion would have a
hundred percent chance of getting third
degree burns that said if you were say
inside of a building or an appliance
that was shielding you from all that it
would actually be far less intense and
entirely survivable case in point a
woman named Akiko takakura survived the
Hiroshima bombing when she was just 300
meters away from the bomb's hyper Center
much much closer than our 5280 feet or
1.61 kilometer distance in Indiana Jones
how'd she get so lucky she was actually
inside of a bank and though she was
burned the building shielded her from
the worst of the effects and it's saved
her life and if we want more proof from
an even more applicable situation during
the test of the 29 kiloton Apple II bomb
in 1955 a Frigidaire chest freezer full
of food was placed in a concrete home
just .89 miles or 1.43 kilometers from
Ground Zero when scientists were able to
move in and examine the damage they
found that the freezer and the food were
relatively unharmed in fact when they
later plugged the freezer in it still
worked all after being less than a mile
from the nuke so all in all it is
feasible that Indy could have beaten the
heat inside of that fridge so what then
about the actual forces and shock waves
created by the explosion for these sorts
of incredibly powerful nuclear bombs
that Blast away from the explosion tends
to work in three stages first there's
the static over pressure which is the
initial shock wave that radiates out
from the blast it is by far the weakest
of the three then you have yourself the
dynamic over pressure which is the big
old gust to wind that blows things away
in all the videos that you tend to see
coming out of these sorts of tests this
is caused by air literally being pushed
away from Ground Zero by the power of
the explosion the dynamic over over
pressure is by far the worst of the
three waves finally we have the receding
flow another gust of wind that goes in
the opposite direction as air rushes in
to fill the temporary vacuum created by
the explosion pushing all the air out of
the way so how powerful would these
blast waves be for a 44 kiloton nuke
again looking back at nuke map the worst
of it would be in the range of 0.81
Miles where the over pressure would be
up to 20 psi resulting in Wind blasts up
to 500 miles an hour that is 805
kilometers an hour but again once you're
outside of that zone things drop off
fast in Indy's case we've established
that the Doom town is a bit outside the
range one mile away so the over pressure
there would only be 5 PSI resulting in
Blast winds that are 163 miles an hour
or 262 kilometers an hour don't get me
wrong that is still the equivalent of a
category 5 hurricane but it is nearly
five times less what it could have been
so with air speeds like that could the
blast wave have launched the
refrigerator like we see in the movie no
definitely not like we see in the movie
in the movie The Fridge is launched so
fast that it literally outruns the blast
wave that Senate flying in the first
place that right there just makes no
scientific sense but in general would
the acceleration have rocketed Indy with
enough Force to damage his body to find
that number we're gonna need to figure
out the acceleration that's put upon the
refrigerator by the explosion and to do
that we use the classic equation or
Force equals mass times acceleration if
we switch that equation around a bit it
becomes acceleration equals force
divided by mass thankfully we can figure
out both the mass and the force using
other information from the film so let's
just start off with mass an average
steel refrigerator weighs only about 250
pounds or 113 kilograms Indy was roughly
60 during the events of kingdom of the
Crystal Skull and the average weight of
a 60 year old man is roughly 195 pounds
or 88.5 kilos but we also have to
remember that this isn't just any
refrigerator this one is lined with lead
for that Superior insulation and let me
tell you lead is heavy if there was a
one inch sheet of lead on every side of
this fridge that would add an additional
3000 in 717 pounds or 1686 kilos right
there totaling out at 4 162 pounds or
1888 kilograms when accounting for the
steel and Indie inside of it yeah all of
that lead adds up fast because a 4 000
pound refrigerator is just a wee bit
ridiculous I also ran the numbers for a
much more reasonable one-tenth of an
inch of lead lining for this thing which
resulted in a total weight of 817 pounds
or 370 and a half kilograms spoiler
alert in the end it didn't make that
much of a difference for Forest we found
the number using the wind speed and the
area of the refrigerator I'm not gonna
bore you with all the numbers here but
basically we use this equation that you
see on screen right now for force with
drag and then we use the air speed of
the atomic blast in the end the fridge
experiences the equivalent of 1.46 G's
of force that's honestly not a lot
ironically the immense weight of a
lead-lined fridge is the thing that
ultimately saves him even with our much
much smaller and more reasonable tenth
of an inch of lead lining number the
g-force's Indie experiences would only
come out to 7.5 geez a bit higher than
some intense roller coasters most humans
can withstand four to six G's pretty
easily fighter pilots are trained to
withstand up to 9 G's for a couple of
seconds while sustained g-forces this
high would absolutely be fatal the
fridge is only flying for about 11
seconds in the movie likely not enough
to actually kill him would he be
uncomfortable absolutely but ultimately
it seems like the forceful flight in the
fridge would be survivable so that is
surprisingly two for two but then what
about our third killer radiation atomic
bombs release an intense amount of
radiation that can be fatal to all those
within range without any protection this
might actually be the most deadly thing
for India in this situation though thin
amounts of lead are able to block
between 90 and 99 of low level radiation
even a foot of lead would be unable to
completely block the most dangerous
gamma rays that are released by these
sorts of atomic bombs that said it
doesn't necessarily mean that all this
is impossible for indeed see the most
deadly radiation from these sorts of
bombs are released in a very small area
and according to Nuke map the
immediately fatal dose of radiation for
the Smoky explosion would have only been
with than 1.59 kilometers just barely
below the 1.61 kilometer distance that
Indy's fridge starts at and considering
that it got pushed away from Ground Zero
by the blast wave he would have ended up
even further away additionally Indy in
the fridge starting out inside of a
house would have done them a lot of good
remember that Frigidaire Freezer that
survived the blast of one of these
Atomic tests and still worked well like
I said there was food inside of that
fridge as part of the test and when
scientists examined the food they found
no traces of radiation inside of it in
fact the food was declared safe for
human consumption and in celebration
people ate it it turns out that the
building it was in took the brunt of the
radiation and shielded everything inside
now to be fair the building was made of
concrete whereas the one in the movie
looks like it's made of more traditional
stuff like woods and metals but that
would still do something to block the
radiation without a doubt Indy would
have had some long-term side effects
from the bomb developing cancer later on
in his life at minimum but for our
purposes today it's plausible that he
survived the radiation too so believe it
or not and I can't believe I'm saying it
but George Lucas wasn't entirely wrong
here Indiana Jones could have feasibly
survived this nuclear explosion inside
of a refrigerator like we see in the
movie now don't get me wrong a lot of
things would have needed to go Indy's
way a lot of things and it is still a
very very stupid scene but by the
Numbers it's not impossible the whole
experts say it'd be 50 50 thing it's
kind of plausible and yet the twist in
all of this is that Indy would still be
guaranteed to die no the nuclear bomb
explosion might not have killed him but
the refrigerator would have see
refrigerators used to be very dangerous
they're designed to be airtight to keep
the contents inside colder and fresher
for longer but that also means that if
someone were to spend any extended
amount of time inside of a fridge they'd
suffocate to death this right here is
known as refrigerator death these days
it's not as big of a threat because
modern refrigerators use magnetism to
keep their doors closed but back when
refrigerators were first hitting the
market it was a massive public threat
early models of refrigerators were
sealed using mechanical latches on the
outside of the door meaning that they
could only be opened from the outside
using that latch this led to a lot of
tragic deaths especially when children
would hide inside of them between
January 1954 and June 1956 there were 54
reported cases of children becoming
trapped inside of household
refrigerators of those 39 died of
asphyxiation this led to massive outcry
from the American people and Decades of
public service announcements warning
kids about the dangers of these sorts of
fridges oh here they come again and I'm
frightened because a child can become
trapped in me and suffocate in 10
minutes even GI Joe got in on the action
oh no check that old refrigerator
thanks for condo eventually this outcry
led the American government to pass the
refrigerator safety act of 1956 making
it illegal to manufacture and sell
fridges that couldn't be opened from the
inside and so you can probably see where
I'm going with this see it's more likely
than not that this fridge that Indy
steps into wouldn't have been able to
open from the inside turning this thing
from his Saving Grace into his coffin
now before some of you call out that
Kingdom the Crystal Skull takes place in
1957 and that the refrigerator safety
Act was passed one year earlier in 1956
remember that every fridge in the
country didn't just immediately switch
over deciphering the legalese here
you'll see that the changeover on the
fridges didn't go into effect until
October 30th of 1958 a full year after
the events of the movie we can even see
Indy pull in a latch to open the fridge
proving that it was one of these older
models so there you have it Indy had a
better chance at surviving an atomic
blast than he did of surviving the
fridge all the heat radiation and blast
waves in the world didn't matter the
minute he stepped into that fridge and
shut the door he was a dead man but hey
we ended up using a lot of physics and
math in today's episode we even had to
cut a lot for time and complication
reasons but thankfully there are ways to
understand this stuff without needing to
actually hop into a refrigerator and
test it yourself one of the best ways to
do it the sponsor of today's video
brilliant.org a free and easy way to
learn all about stem subjects here at
theist our whole thing has taken stories
that you love and then using them to
teach people about science math and
Technology breaking down these really
daunting topics with stuff that's more
accessible like an archaeologist running
away from a boulder brilliant is doing
the exact same sort of thing customizing
your learning experience with
interactive content that lets you move
at your own pace all on topics that
range from basic algebra and logic
puzzles to Quantum Computing and search
engine algorithms above all though
brilliant just wants to help you reach
your learning goals no matter how
aggressive they might be brilliant is
quick and easy to use and built for
people with busy lives so whether you're
a student with an already packed
schedule or an archaeologist traveling
to ruins across the world brilliant can
help you fit even more learning into
your life as someone with something to
do basically every waking hour of of
every day I really appreciate Brilliance
approach I found their physics of the
everyday course awesome letting me brush
up on how everything from toilets and
fridges work before working up to
nuclear energy and reactors so if you
want to check out all the awesome
learning that brilliant has to offer all
for free for the next 30 days check out
brilliant.org film Theory or just click
the link in the top line of the
description again that is
b-r-i-l-l-i-a-n-t dot org slash
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y or again just click
the link so you don't have to spell it
all out the first 200 loyal theorists to
sign up will get themselves 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
thank you again to brilliant and
remember guys it's all just a theory a
film Theory and cut